there's millions of dollars inside these
envelopes meet Josh Fox if you want to
change your life this is the
conversation for you you can make 6.3
million dollars we love money in the
past few years fox has built an Empire
recently with some assistance from Shark
Tank investor Kevin O'Leary by taking
advantage of an obscure pandemic era tax
break the employee retention credit
program do you even know what that is
this is the modern day Gold Rush that's
what I'm calling it oh this is a total
Gold Rush since 2021 Fox's firm bottom
line Concepts has worked with thousands
of small businesses and non-profits in
an effort to pursue more than six
billion dollars in tax breaks which
could yield bottom line more than one
billion dollars in fees
but is this Gold Rush too good to be
true one of the things we've seen with
these pandemic programs is when you do
things in a in a hurry you have
unintended consequences
in March of 2020 as the coronavirus
pandemic first gripped the country
president Trump signed the two trillion
dollar cares act I've never signed
anything with a Tiana
the largest economic stimulus package in
U.S history one of the Lesser known
parts of that legislation was the
employer retention tax credit or ERC
there was real concern during the
pandemic that people would get laid off
and lose some of that attachment to a
particular employer and it'd be harder
to turn the economy back on again the
real core point of this credit was to
keep workers attached to their jobs to
qualify for the ERC a business or
non-profit must meet certain criteria to
get in you have to be one of two tests
either your revenue is a drop by a
specific amount the other way is used to
have to have a government order that was
fully or partially suspending your
business the amount of business can
qualify for depends on its number of
employees and which quarters the
business was affected during the
pandemic the number you'll see really
frequently in all the ads is 26 000 per
employee see if your company qualifies
for up to twenty six thousand dollars
per employee and I think that's
basically five thousand per employee in
2020 which which was the limit and then
seven thousand for the each of the first
three quarters in 2021 which was the
limit for that year so you'll see this
twenty six thousand per employee number
that's the maximum you could qualify for
if you were eligible for all of those
quarters determining if a business
qualifies for the ERC and for how much
isn't straightforward it's also a
challenge for the IRS the employer
retention credit is an extremely
complicated uh filing to process that's
where firms like bottom line Concepts
come in so I've got the expert with me
this is Josh Fox although the ERC
expired in late 2021 the window to claim
the credit retroactively remains open
until early 2025. I want you to get this
money you'd be crazy not to get this to
find eligible businesses firms like
bottom line are advertising heavily
what's the ERC you ask Shark Tank
veteran Kevin O'Leary his bottom Line's
best known partner what is this this is
uh hundreds of millions of dollars
literally Kevin O'Leary told the Wall
Street Journal why he joined forces with
bottom line I said look
I need to buy a piece of the company I
need to be a shareholder but in this
case it made no sense because this
program is going away in a matter of
months so I said let's form a new entity
let's be partners in it we're going to
call it Wonder trust Wonder trust is a
website that connects potential
businesses with bottom line I will get
behind this I'll go all over network
television all over social
and tell people about this program
because I'm a Believer in it and I'll
put my own companies through it so I'll
eat my own cooking Mr Wonderful here and
there's no debate about this Wonder
trust said it has submitted about 140
million dollars in ERC claims for more
than 780 employers I'm pounding the
table I'm telling
most small businesses know who I am and
I'm telling them this is mandate number
one you have months left
to look into this and you should for the
businesses that are unconvinced or
unreceptive to commercials bottom line
has also created a referral network of
about 50 000 people these are people who
are not on salary bottom line they may
have another job they may be semi
retired they may be fully retired
um and they're just out there talking to
every employer they can find what else
are the people on this call doing
there's 600 people today on the call
that you can make 6.3 million dollars
one of the tools bottom line is used to
recruit potential Affiliates is online
video one of the videos is called become
a millionaire with bottom line so 100
clients divided by 24 months you have to
bring us
four clients a month they run through
the math you know bring me these number
of people and look how much money
you can make so one client a week
for two years you make a million three
we're making millionaires this is easy
money it's a way to get rich Carrie
hagensmith is a bottom line Concepts
referral partner hagensmith is working
with 24 clients that she expects will
receive about 1.4 million dollars back
from the IRS they have not all gotten
their paperwork in yet so it's a very
long process both on the client side and
on bottom line Concept side and then we
add the third element which is the IRS
processing haggensmith said her success
has come primarily from face-to-face
interactions my biggest strategy has
been with a partner and I we go bold
calling that's not wimping out and cold
calling on the phone that's walking
bold-faced into the businesses door and
actually being the local face that they
can rely on for ERC answers bottom line
doesn't require its customers to Shell
out cash instead everyone gets paid once
the IRS issues a check you don't have to
buy anything you don't have to spend a
lot of money up front you don't have to
convince your clients to write you a
check you get money at the end once
everyone is happy and you're helping
small businesses along the way that's
the pitch everything we do we're doing
because you've signed a contract and
you're going to get the actual check
back from the IRS that's it that
alleviates a lot of those fears that
people have from hearing the scam alerts
I actually started digging into it and
looked at people that could process
these applications
I came to the inclusion there's a lot of
well for lack of a better word
schlocksters out there despite his
support for the ERC O'Leary acknowledges
that there are some unscrupulous firms
involved in the ERC space I think
anybody that takes a payment up front
I would not use them because why are
they doing that every year as the nation
heads into tax season the IRS releases a
list of the most common tax scams for
taxpayers to be mindful of at the top of
that list for 2023 was fraudulent ERC
claims for the IRS the ERC is a giant
headache on the one hand what's happened
is because they've gotten so many
applications there have been a lot of
complaints that they haven't processed
these refunds quickly enough and I've
talked to small businesses who need the
money who really feel they qualify and
they haven't and they've been waiting on
the other hand the IRS is really worried
about fraud figuring out whether what's
legal here and what's not is is really
tricky I think we're very much in the
early stages of that you know the IRS
has certainly indicated that it thinks
it is seeing and the IRS does not name
particular firms in this
but they've indicated that they're
seeing what they think are a significant
number of fraudulent or overstated or
ineligible claims
in a statement to the Wall Street
Journal bottom line wrote we are proud
of the company's record of delivering
valuable services to American businesses
with no upfront fees and a compliant and
transparent manner including educating
small businesses on the ERC program and
helping them reinvest in their business
and their Workforce to the benefit of
local communities across the country
look at all these checks I am actually
holding in my hand